hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and i'm here
to be very emotionally invested in
characters that really meant nothing to
me less than a week ago
don't make eliza sad make sure you like
and subscribe and let's get into the
meaty meaty story
episode 56 wait who's she that lady in
the opening scenes
oh hang on it's kurapika wow he looks
good in an icy blonde
there were a lot of revelations this
episode on both sides there's a lot to
be said for the perspectives we get to
sit in
the setup of basho's death was very
clear in fact i signaled it last episode
or the episode before they wanted us to
care about bashar they wanted it to be
meaningful i think that's the right name
i
don't know they wanted it to be
meaningful so let's take a look at that
first because we were sort of
manipulated into seeing him a different
way and caring about him very quickly
hunter hunter has a few different
mechanisms for giving us insight into
characters and it's always interesting
which ones they choose
rather than using the isolation
technique they've used in the past where
a character enters a dark
single coloured realm inside their minds
in this case they decided to humanize
basho by having him speak his thoughts
to his hounds
the softness and innocence of that
especially as he looked for jobs that
would fit all of them rather than just
himself in eliza
lent itself to a sense of martyrdom when
he was killed he released the dog so
they wouldn't have to see what happened
so they
wouldn't be subjected to the situation
he could see himself getting into
and all of those things gave his death a
really impressive amount of importance
and of course eliza knowing added to
that impact giving her a frame or two of
awareness
that something had happened showed us
just how much they did
actually care for each other and put a
value on his death which doesn't happen
often in this show
uvogen dying was one such value death
and look where it led basho's death may
not lead to an outcome as narratively
impactful but compared to all the
mafia security that were killed a few
episodes ago to classical music were not
spared the emotional importance of this
moment which wouldn't have been
important at all had there not been a
link between bashar and eliza and
between basha and his dogs
who as seen in the hotel room genuinely
cared for him
so rest in pieces basho your death had
more impact than your life unfortunately
but at least we got to experience it
with you in our next perspective we got
melody back in our story again what i
don't understand that i really want to
is why melody has never been on any of
the face pages we've had for the
nostrada family security
neither melody nor korapika are featured
are they the only hunters
who or what is protecting them if not
will that ever be explained
melody is seeing korapika's behavior and
despite not knowing him for that long
i guess have any of them known any of
the others for that long
not really she has a good indication of
what is normal for him and what's not
she's hugely insightful our friend
melody which i guess comes from the
combination of knowing the sound of
people's bodies and hearts and minds and
something that i suspect is uniquely
hers she hooked onto karapika in an
instant and i
keep wondering whether that's by design
for her obviously it's by design in the
narrative
is it just that she wants friends or is
it more she's very often the steadying
hand on karapika's arm but
why nobunaga went on a journey today
for the first time we saw him use his
sword actually probably not the first
time but the first time we saw him
essentially lose his cool in an extreme
enough way to kill someone pakunoda also
went on a journey
as did them today's sorry i can't help
it they're so
obviously there i just don't understand
the physics of them
anyway it was great to see that she has
more than one ability i wonder whether
her memory bomb would have a mundane
effect on a normal person
we saw a voguing get shot and not care
is it the same for them were they using
nen at the time to prevent the shot
actually hurting them that final shot of
nobunaga
the art involved in that was frankly
beautiful and feels like it was a redraw
of
literally the manga ending there are
some frames that come up in this show
that make it feel more like manga than
anime and i really like how those how
they choose those frames and
when something i found really
fascinating and really enjoyed getting
insight into was krollo's appraisal of
god
the time he took to look at gone
suggests to me that he actually sees why
nobunaga wanted gon to join the phantom
troop how do i know that's something he
actually considered he answered the
question
he answered the question he didn't need
to answer and he took the time to think
about the response as though it might be
particularly important for a future
sales pitch which it might i can't
imagine gone deciding to join the
phantom troop but at the same time i
could
kind of actually imagine him joining the
phantom troop to give corapica the
chance to attack
knowing that pakunoda is away means that
korapika is safe for a short time and
that's why gon revealed himself he had
to
i'm excited to see where this leads
because nobunaga has entirely missed out
on all the fun of catching his mortal
enemy as well as the kid he forgot he
wanted to recruit to the troop which
seems
odd still actually meanwhile leorio is
missing out on everything because he's
stuck in traffic
are we surprised no this team needed a
driver and he's the perfect
person them oh and one more thing before
we move on to the next episode
i have never heard anything more
hardcore in my life than
if we get closer they might sense my
animosity oh my god corapica
so intense episode 57 god i love a good
heist which is exactly what this episode
was
a heist movie but in 20 minutes and an
anime with characters were already
attached to
at least that's the beginning of the
situation why is it that quiloia
continues to be the perspective of level
headed that we go with what is it about
him that we as an audience are supposed
to think
yes this here this guy here this dude
madude is the voice of reason he was an
assassin so he must have some pretty
good executive function though
brother seems to have hypnotized him
with some kind of permanent effect one
might call it trauma
so he's compromised but of the
perspectives he's the least compromised
i guess since we can't count on gon or
lyorio to be practical enough to think
through a plan that quickly
so fine yes on balance kilowatt's the
best option for reasoning these things
through and making quick choices
also i guess i should congratulate gone
on managing to get their attention for a
second though he didn't come up with the
plan or in fact complete the plan
he just sort of stumbled around and got
in the way enough to solve the problem
which is what he does best good job
kurapika for putting the right person in
the way
sometimes i love my notes let me read
some for you
strong boobs yes in the moment that i
typed that i'd forgotten the name
pakonoda
and could only remember her by her
defining feature i mean she has two
defining features neither of which are
as pronounced in the flashback i might
earned
her nose and her boobs are both sort of
hidden at that point i don't know how
they're hidden
and you can't hide a nose nose is just
not as
big how does do you does your nose
really grow that much after puberty
we'll talk more about that later but
paco noda is either really strong or
these two teenagers are really
really light returning to the teenagers
for a moment something i've noticed
several times that i haven't commented
on is their seeming ability to share
information without anyone else hearing
them either they're having the same
thoughts simultaneously which i'm
incredibly impressed about or
something else is happening i really
don't know it feels like they have a
shared voice in those moments and i'm
always a bit confused by it when it
happens
why not just stick with kilwa's voice i
suppose because we need to know that
god's also having the thought
but why not in that time split the
screen or something why does it
look so specifically like they're
sharing a conversation
they're not looking at each other or
having any contact and we don't have any
precedent for them having a shared
language
so i don't really understand the
intention behind the technique anyway
just something i've been thinking about
for a while you know i often
underestimate lyorio's intelligence
because his behavior is so loud and
brash but he's training to be a doctor
so he has to be at least capable for
that which puts him at probably the most
intelligent member of the party in
pure intelligence doesn't mean he's wise
but he's starting to get the idea that
he looks
older working for him and that's great a
plan is only as good as its weakest
member and at this point in the game i
think the weakest member is
actually probably kurapika whose passion
and animosity have in fact made clear a
weakness even without crowler knowing
the rest of
the you know weakness situation that he
shared with the rest of the group
speaking of crollow poor thing his team
are gonna do what he says because he's
cared for them too well
they're too well bonded and care too
much about each other they cared about
uvogin and pakinota put her finger on it
he died because he wanted to protect the
others
he saw that as worth it crollow managed
to terrify melody with his conviction
that the spider is what matters not him
which makes him seem like a freedom
fighter or martyr more than a leader the
problem is that the ideal he holds falls
by the wayside for half the group
because they care about him as a person
and do things for him not just because
he's the boss but because
he's a friend and carer returning time
and time again to the importance of
relationships and revenge in this series
the fracture in the way the spider works
and the breaking of that web is
fascinating they're all loyal just in
vastly different ways and i really
appreciate the delicacy of how that
works
we know nobunaga is passionate so of
course he'll fall on the emotional side
of things but i was surprised to find
that vacuum woman did too
the three guys made sense too actually
we've had less screen time with them to
date and this series tends to put more
focus on those who are passionate the
characters we want to
see or that they think we want to see
are deeply passionate in their
convictions
it's not an incorrect assumption to make
either schmickenshmami
i can't remember his name the guy that
picks up the phone first he got screen
time because he tried to control the
conversation and had to fall back on
hilarious apologies
crollo is a beautiful character simply
because he doesn't look as though he's
exhibiting
external passion but there is passion in
every movement he makes and every
word he says his passion is shown
through those words and actions rather
than in facial expression which is why
he's a great exception to what's
happening
in fact he's quite the opposite to
hisoka who can't keep his tongue in his
mouth or his swing out of his step i had
to watch the end of this episode twice
on that note because i didn't understand
really what was happening in hisoka's
mind he wants to fight crolo but not
kill him does hisoka think he could take
on crollo i really don't understand the
situation there
i mean we know hisoka likes to fight
people but i'm surprised he wants to
fight the boss but not
kill the boss does he want to fight gone
but not kill gone i thought he wanted to
kill gon
or was there a translation error
somewhere i didn't really get it
maybe i will next episode i'm not
willing to end on that note because it
feels really uncertain so i will end on
this one
misha or whatever her name is has
incredible abs and i want them
abs that can trap a hand gimme i want
that power
and on that note we shall leave this
episode because that's it from me
if you enjoyed this content and you want
more feel free to hit the like dislike
and or subscribe buttons
you can also click here here here
probably here somewhere over here and
you can tap a tap tap something
else for something magical to happen
while i go get candy cause who am i
kidding hardcore fitness ain't me have a
great day bye